backstreet boys Sun is hitting Broadway
Brian Littrell Sun opening in the new
show disaster becoming a
second-generation showbiz kid and you
know what his dad is beaming crowd he
wants it that way up in push down push
Brown when will I be luck like father
like son
13-year old bailey is kind of a new
generation Backstreet Boy his turn in
the Broadway musical disaster is earning
rave reviews what was your reaction when
you heard you landed the part my room a
couple times and that was pretty much it
we knew Bailey had the performance gene
when we covered the then seven-year-old
wedding singer at his parents vow
renewal
I think it's incredible Bailey that you
George with the Backstreet Boys history
I asked him if I could and then he said
you can sing a couple songs and I was
like wait did he just say yes I loved it
Bailey already has Stage Door fans a
healthy teen today when he was younger
he suffered from a serious medical
condition that inflamed the blood
vessels around his heart you battled
Kawasaki disease how did you come
through that to be able to do everything
that you've achieved I don't know I
don't know I think it gave me a lot more
strength and like courage to know that I
handled that and I remember I walked out
of the hospital and a Batman costume and
I was like I walked out of here when I
survived this and then everything is
going to be amazing
you know at the height of his Backstreet
Boys Fame Brian also had a health scare
going through open heart surgery at 22
years old then being a parent and in a
helpless situation like that it was a
very very trying time our faith in our
life has always been our foundation
Brian and wife LeAnn moved the family
from Atlanta to New York to support
Bailey's Broadway dreams he's planning
to make a career of Jobos what about
joining a boy bands following in you
know I said it's tough I was like to
follow in his footsteps solo mm-hmm
well the showbiz life can be tough on a
family and a lot of traveling but brian
says wherever they are that's where they
make their home a tour bus a hotel room
or an apartment they are just happy to
be together
you